today I'm going to talk about a very
very fun and exciting experiment that
was worked on by one of the students
that I'm fortunate enough to work with
at UC San Diego and that's Alyssa
Johnson who was an undergraduate at
Humboldt State University which part of
the Great California State University
system Alyssa is a graduate student in
our new astronomy program at UC San
Diego she worked on this experiment and
she prepared these incredible slides
that's going to take you through an
experiment that's looking for deviations
from the gravitational force that we
know and love and keeps us bound to the
Earth that's the inverse Square law well
how do we know the inverse Square law
truly holds over all length scales from
the largest scales in the cosmos to the
smallest these are small but the ones
out there are far away we've talked in
other videos like this one with
Professor Mordecai Milgram about his
theory which is called mondified
Newtonian Dynamics which explains away
the need for dark matter by instead
invoking a new form of gravitational
force that operates not on local scales
but on Cosmic scales between galaxies
and internal dynamics of galaxies to
explain the peculiar rotation curves of
galaxies first observed by Vera Reuben
Vera Rubin was trained right here at UC
San Diego by none other than my late
great colleagues Margaret and Jeffrey
Burbage but this is about a short-range
gravity experiment not on Galaxy scales
like this but in the laboratory scales
and results are described in this paper
which you can find yourself for free on
the archive at the link that's shown in
the screen now so why should we test
gravity at short distance skills it's
kind of nicely summarized here Gravity
has not been tested well below the sub
millimeter scale where you might be able
to First sense the effects of quantum
gravitational effects those are
obviously much much smaller than the
millimeter scale but they're not as
small relatively speaking as say from
the table top or laboratory scale on
Earth to the entire Cosmos that the
modified Newtonian gravity proposals
seek to Define life is like this I want
to make that smaller gr and quantum
mechanics are in commensurate
incompatible with each other and so
you'd like to study that close to the
regime scale which both effects are
operative namely on the small scales and
um the gravitational force fields that
we can test in the laboratory and lastly
if we could unify the standard model of
particle physics and general relativity
we could potentially have the so-called
Theory of Everything and that may come
in our lifetimes or it may not come at
all there's no guarantee that forces and
Fields have to be unified just because
that approach has worked so successfully
throughout the past 100 years in the
Golden Age of physics that we've been
enjoying for quite some time so what is
the inverse Square law well that's
merely the fact observed encapsulated
Newton's famous equation that the
gravitational force field between two
gravitating massive objects X depends on
the product of their masses times a
universal constant called capital G
Newton's constant and the inverse of the
square of the distance between them
there could be alterations of this
inverse Square law at small scales that
has so far evaded our detection because
it's so difficult to measure the effects
of gravity when you're talking about
things that are smaller than say the
length scale of your fingernails it's
actually easier to detect gravitational
forces between planets and say the Moon
and the Earth than it is between objects
that are separated by Micron distance
scales as paradoxical as that may sound
you'd think it'd be easier to measure
forces over short distance scales and of
course these divergences of the force if
you go to zero separation formally
Newton's law is predicting an infinite
force between two massive objects but
what does that really mean can you
really get two massive classical objects
to be located in infinitesimal distance
away now you can't but the question is
as you approach infinitesimal distances
from finite distances can you get a
deviation from 1 over r squared Behavior
that's what this research in Alyssa and
her advisor worked on at Humboldt State
so where are we currently well there are
a series of experiments that have been
carried out these are really classical
physics experiments that are being done
with modern technology at the University
of Washington their so-called advosh
experiments and the joke is that their
name of the experiment is at wash where
wash is for Washington and they're
looking for this equation that would
parameterize a new gravitational
potential rather than diverging as one
over R the force goes as the gradient or
the derivative with respect to R of the
potential so if the potential varies is
1 over r that means the force will go as
one over r squared in this case the
potential doesn't go just as 1 over R
the first leading term in the equation
for v as a function of r potential
energy as a function of r does depend as
Inver first on the distance but then
there's a modification a so-called
yukawa term which traces its name to the
famous Japanese physicist yukawa who
predicted the behavior of subatomic
particles in the strong nuclear force
pions and so forth that was governed by
a yukawa term that fell off as an
exponential not as an inverse power law
and so by modifying the coupling from
just being one inside the square
brackets to being one plus this
exponentially decaying term which is
parametrized by two numbers the length
scale over which it decays which is
Lambda and some amplitude which is an
energy scale which is Alpha you have
this two-dimensional parameter space of
Alpha and Lambda so the amount of the
deviation and potential Alpha is plotted
here on the right as a function of the
inverse of the length scale over which
the deviation from inverse Square law
take place in the Humboldt State
University experiment Hsu they predict
they could get down to even lower values
than these world-beating experiment at
University of Washington and they're
working with the same team members as
you'll see if you read the paper we'll
show the paper here those authors are
collaborators at the University of
Washington so at Humboldt State
University the lab that Alyssa was
working in with her advisor looked like
this so they have a gravitational
research lab where they're doing what's
called torsion pendulum a torsion
pendulum is a pendulum that doesn't tick
back and forth by swinging like a
grandfather clock but instead twist back
and forth like a plate on a on a string
the amount of twisting as you bring in a
closer plate to the torsion pendulum's
Bob again it's not oscillating in a
plane it's oscillating about an axis
back and forth and they measure that
deviation as they bring in another
material perhaps made of a different
substance as the main pendulum is made
up of so they've got a torsion pendulum
with equal masses so they have two
plates separated by some distance and
this makes what's called a composition
dipole if they're different materials
you could do a similar materials or you
could do it with different materials and
the actual Foundation of this experiment
goes back to Cavendish in the 1700s
making these measurements and torsion
pendulums as well it's a classic
experiment we do in physics Labs but
this is on steroids with the Humboldt
State University's team and approach to
it so the attractor Mass causes the
deflecting Mass to oscillate and that
creates a time-dependent torque on the
pendulum and then you measure the period
of the pendulum the size of its
oscillation as a function of the
separation between the attractor mass
and the Pendulum Mass itself and this
allows you to look for deviations in
What's called the weak equivalence
principle or in the inverse Square law
and again this could be parameterized by
these two parameters Alpha and Lambda so
this is not an easy experiment to do in
fact I tried a version of the Cavendish
experiment 30 years ago as a freshman at
Case Western Reserve University go
Spartans and that measurement I got an
answer that was some 10 orders of
magnitude off from the acceptable value
of capital G in Newton's constant that's
embarrassing but lucky for me the tenure
committee at UC San Diego never knew
about those freshman lab blunders that
yours truly made gravity is incredibly
weak there are interactions
electrostatic interactions magnetic
interactions the test masses have to be
brought in from different distances and
changed and measured over those
distances there can be variations in
temperature as there often are diurnally
throughout the day the building has its
own environmental effects it has
vibrational effects students come into
the laboratory environment they go into
classrooms there's traffic on the
streets all these things can be sensed
by this exquisitely sensitive machine
built at Humboldt State University they
have to keep isolated as best as
possible the experimental apparatus from
the surrounding environment but you
can't launch it into space at least on
the budget of a California State
University like UCSD or Humboldt State
University so they make use of
incredible Precision control over the
environment including vacuum shielding
magnetically electrostatic grounding and
what's called an active leveling system
that is the key enabling device at some
level the tilts in the apparatus can can
affect the measurement at the Micron
level and that's very important for
ruling out so-called systematic errors
errors in the system not in the
fundamental forces and it could confuse
you that you've measured a deviation
from the inverse Square law when
actually it was just a deviation of your
apparatus's tilt so they actually build
in what's called temperature
compensation where they can stretch or
Shrink the length of a leg of their
apparatus to compensate for thermal
variations in the laboratory or in the
apparatus itself they can measure this
as they have here and they can see the
tiny this is millionth of a radian
radians about 57 degrees so you're
measuring 57 1 millionths of a degree
tilt and you're doing that with very
high accuracy over many many day long
experimental data acquisition periods
it's really quite impressive that they
can do this and they need to do this to
make contributions that people will
believe through our understanding of
gravity at small scales here's a block
diagram a schematic diagram of how the
compensation Works what's called a PID
or emotional integral derivative control
system this is what's called a Servo
system that uses Corrections and
measurements like a thermostat does it
measures the difference between what you
set the temperature at and what the room
is actually reading then applies heat or
cold to compensate but you can overshoot
very easily and get into an oscillation
with a thermostat unless you damp that
by constraining What's called the
integral term and applying a dissipative
term a derivative term to correct for
the oscillation so that you get a nice
stable Solution that's controllable
that's predictable and this is called
tuning the PID circuit which is
something Alyssa spent a lot of her time
doing labview which is a nice GUI
graphical user interface programming
term which is very common in
instructional laboratory so if you come
here to UC San Diego or you go to
Humboldt State University you'll get
great experience doing control over
Servo Motors and heaters and resistors
and thermometers and doing everything
digitally acquiring and sampling an
analog signal temperature length Etc and
then converting that to a digital signal
null and then correcting and
compensating applying compensatory
signals to make a very stable and active
control system and this type of
technique is using everything from these
tabletop type gravity experiments all
the way up to the ligo experiment that
we've talked about many times including
with the two of the three leaders a
Nobel Prize winners Barry barish and
with Ray Weiss on this very channel so
here's a recording measurement where
Alyssa is showing her data from the
laboratory tuning to get not an overall
small value of the Tilt although that
would be nice but to get smaller and
smaller variations and oscillations in
the amount of tilt over time and you see
the very first runs that shown at the
top with no components of proportional
integral derivative included and then
the final term which has the lowest
variation the lowest oscillatory
Behavior over 1.2 days worth of data and
that shows the best behavior and you see
the little interruptions that looks like
hash in the data those could be from
people coming in the building going out
of the building there's some periodic
things it could be from everything from
interference from Wi-Fi to other effects
that can be filtered out but the goal
has been achieved with just two terms
this proportional term and the
derivative term damping out the
oscillations but also correcting so that
when it's too big a tilt you're correct
you heat or you control the length of
the apparatus keeping it stable and its
overall magnitude as small as possible
so they're still working on this they're
still trying to improve the Tilt over
time the smaller they can get it the
more accurate they can measure both
Alpha and Lambda so they want to have
Tighter and Tighter feedback control but
you can't Over Control you can risk
sending the system into an oscillation
that also is unstable and doesn't
improve your measurement whatsoever and
they want to understand and characterize
their instrument much better and you can
read more about the results and The
Cutting Edge nature of the field in
these papers and there's a paper in
progress that Alyssa herself has been
working on so stay tuned for that look
at the work of Professor Doyle at
Humboldt State and stay tuned soon for
great results from both the edvos team
and the Hsu team and stay tuned for more
work from Alissa Johnson a rising star
who were lucky enough to have here at
the UC San Diego system where she's
studying gravity in the laboratory if
you think of the entire Cosmos as our
laboratory she's working on Simon's
Observatory measurements of primordial
gravitational wave radiation
so if you like this measurement you'd
like to learn more about experimental
searches for Gravity click here for this
video about ligo
I'll see you in the next video
foreign